when you're ready to start solving on
the cloud
the google cloud free program is a great
place to start
so what does that actually include once
you create your new account you'll have
300
in credits for the first 90 days to use
across all of google cloud
and don't worry even once you've used
your credits or finished your 90 days
you won't be charged unless you manually
upgrade your account
once you upgrade you'll keep your cloud
resources and any remaining credits
plus with the free tier new and existing
users can take advantage of many of
google cloud services
entirely for free these services can be
used within a monthly limit
letting you build and test new solutions
on innovative technology including
running virtual machines serverless
container hosting or data analysis
entirely for free each service has
different limits so try them out without
worrying about costs
on top of all that you'll also get 200
in monthly credits towards usage of
google maps platform products
get started with google cloud for free